[Music]
everyone I'm Danny directed oh this is
Daley Denny live and I'm so excited
because sitting across from me is
fourteen-year-old girl wonder powerhouse
vocals sensation from America's Got
Talent
mr. Courtney had wind what's going on
court how are you how you feeling now
that all this attention has been well
deserved of course but now that you've
made it to the quarterfinals
excuse me semifinals yeah I imagine it
is you're only 14 years old and I got to
say you're an old soul so before we get
into all these awesome questions that I
have I do want to ask you about Aretha
Franklin cuz Aretha of course we learned
today that she's passed at 76 years old
and I always said I actually tweeted
this this morning that her music is so
timeless
you know like six decades of music and
anybody knows who Aretha is knows her
songs and you of course have a habit of
singing some old classics you know from
Tina Turner to James Brown what does a a
wreath is life and legacy mean to you
what has her what has her music meant to
you like James and Janis Joplin and I
just think over the years I've learnt so
much from her music and she actually
brought me into this kind of music does
she you had this kind of like soul rock
you know cuz she really defied those
kind of genres right she was seeing
anything she's in the book do you have a
favorite Aretha Franklin song I think
thank mmm any chance we could hear you
singing on a GT this season no maybe do
you have a read that have you set a
singer and Aretha cover before yeah what
song think yeah okay sounds perfect for
you I'm so excited it sounds perfect for
you because your first audition I mean
wow it's already racked over 40 I think
46 million views and Counting on YouTube
and I think I told you this on the red
carpet that when we first watched it
everyone here at the office was just
going nuts for you because obviously you
know you're like any fourteen-year-old
kid and so you come on the stage and
you're someone else if you guys didn't
catch it I do want to play them a little
clip from it isn't
apart from your audition she's like
being nervous about it take a look at
this this is our first audition before
she became Howie's golden buzzer take a
look
[Music]
[Applause]
I cannot get over that I just can't look
at everyone's reaction how he getting up
I love Tyra's at the end like okay
that's how we all fell I saw your dad
make a little cameo in there I mean what
does it feel like watching back that
performance what did that moment feel
like and it just feels leave watching it
back does it and then getting all the
views come on through and people like
Anna it's just just amazing
it's so cool I mean obviously it paid
off because then you became how he's
golden buzzer we got one right here
I mean what was your reaction when you
heard that how he hit your golden buzzer
and when how we hit the golden was I
just didn't expect at all because when I
went over comp went in the competition I
thought that was actually gonna get the
red buzzers really yeah because back in
England like when I did the voice kids
because we did that and it was like it
was exposure and it led me to another
short and when I did that people most
people didn't really get me as much as
they did welcome to America really yeah
what do you think why do you think that
is what is it why do you think Americans
have just all of a sudden latched on t
and been like wow she's the real deal
in in the UK where I'm from the use of
all the the pop usual normal acts
however when in the America they've had
like Janis Joplin everyone originated
from here again cuz it's like timeless
you know it's classics that everyone
knows and loves and when it when they
hear out of a voice like yours you know
out of a person like you that looks like
you it's kind of unexpected I think how
he even said it was the most unexpected
audition from AGT which made it so
special if you guys are just joining us
I'm live with Courtney had when I
already see your comments coming in if
you have any questions for Courtney let
us know in the comment section but I
gotta let you know right away that these
couple of people are writing in Greg
Biggs from u2 says you were brilliant
Courtney Sally from Facebook is saying
you've got soul all the way down to your
told toes I mean where's
come from where where did you arm where
did your love of music and this type of
music come from I kind of just watched a
James Brown video and everything and I
feel good yeah and then I kind of just
cook try to cut me a few moves but look
at that I couldn't do them properly so
they kinda turned into my own movie
which is amazing right no I you you got
the essence of James Brown but you're
right it's totally you which is so fun I
was gonna say do you practice those
dance moves in the mirror before your
audition or before performance cuz you
got a nail down and some of the dance
moves are like like I wouldn't say
choreographed but I know where I'm going
but then when I'm on stage and I failed
and I think it kind of sometimes just
changes I talked to Holly on the red
carpet this week after the quarterfinals
and he said that he doesn't know where
it comes from but all of a sudden the
music hits and you become possessed I
mean do you feel like yourself up there
do you go do you transport to another
place and channel people like Janis
Joplin it's like when I'm on stage and
nervous to go on and then when I go on
stage it's like everything goes blank
and it's feel the music yeah it's almost
like you're just dancing and enjoying
your like the time by yourself right
like dancing and singing like no one's
watching does it feel that way yeah well
let me tell you a lot of eyes are
watching that a lot of people are
watching a Peggy Lee from facebook says
never lose your originality you're
amazing great from YouTube says Courtney
or is asking what inspired you to go on
a GT and show your talent and seeing
people like Chris Fonda WA and Darcy Lin
who were like the same age of me and
then go on in the short and perform or
sing I'll do whatever they do and show
everyone just made me want to do that to
my right and they did it well too and of
course they won they won the whole thing
I mean do you feel that pressure to kind
of follow their lead you know have you
had a chance to talk to any of them and
yeah well in the quarterfinals me and
Darcy
we were qualifying every weekend from
the world
talking to each other that's amazing
have you gotten to really get to know
your fellow contestants I know you and
Amanda were up for elimination together
last night during the results show you
both got through and I noticed that you
were so excited for a man as much as you
were for yourself I mean what's that
bond like I think before before we went
on we didn't really talk to each other
and we weren't I wouldn't say not
friends but we just didn't talk to each
other and then as soon as we got put up
against Rita for we were like okay and
then when we were found out we ran over
and hugged each other and we came
upstairs talking to each other and felt
like we've been friends for ages I love
that so now that the pressures kind of
off because you guys are both advancing
and it's kind of now you can be friends
exactly right she's also an amazing
voice right yeah some other comments
coming in Valerie of Valyria from
facebook says love her blew me away my
jaw drop girl has pipes on her Peggy
says the moment I heard your voice I
thought immediately of Janis Joplin you
are what the music world needs again if
you were to win a GT and and there's
million dollar prize what would you do
with it and what kind of direction do
you want to go with your own music and I
haven't really thought about when energy
is because you want jinx it are you just
like or focused on each performance I
just think that I should be in the
competition to have fun whatever happens
happens for a reason I love that
Courtney then forget my question you
should be having fun no the money will
come you got to just keep doing what
you're doing
so Schaeffer YouTube actually has a
great question who is your favorite or
current artist right now
um do they have to be like in 2018 yeah
like what are you listening to right now
I really like Christina Aguilera yes did
she just put out a new record right yeah
were you listening to her old sub - I
just I just love her songs thanks Scott
laughs a friend
and she she was inspired by Aretha
Franklin at James people like that she's
one of those pop singers who has radio
hits but has a voice like soul singers
like a wreath in Adele right yeah who
was your dream collaboration like who's
an artist you would love to be on a song
with there have to be alive no let's do
dead or alive I love that right if three
words it would be pick three let's do it
yeah who would you want to collab with
Jonas jump and James Brown
Aretha Franklin so good I love that I
got to just tell you right now there's
so much love and support coming your way
everyone's saying they will vote for you
I mean I can tell you you like hear in
the comments but you're that good so I'm
so excited for you um before I let you
go guys she's actually about to catch a
flight back home right after this uh
what's the first thing you do when you
get there in England in England back
home yeah I'm gonna get the car down on
my knees and run and go and get my dog I
have a Yorkshire Terrier I mean what
were you doing before egt what was life
like for you I'm sure school and and you
have a couple siblings out here as well
yeah I have a sister and was it just
like school were you ever like do you
play an instrument and I've always
wanted to play piano but I feel like I
can't sit down on the piano and sit
there put in there have to be moving all
right
what's up everything about home like
what do you like to do for fun sing
scale yeah I think I do my homework I go
on the show or not and that's the same
every time
so this is a culture shock I'm sure this
is a different vibe for you right I mean
you just played up the the home of the
Academy Awards and she'll be bad guys
she made it to the semi-finals Courtney
thank you so much for hanging out with
us you know I'm already guaranteeing
that you'll be getting pretty far and I
can't wait to buy your first record
thanks for being with us
and thank you guys for hanging out with
those two singing on all those wonderful
questions send your love
Courtney's way you know how to find her
on social media and we'll be back
tomorrow with another daily Denny you
guys thank you so much and enjoy your
Thursday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]